let's take the hypothetical author
that's just written their first novel
and now they're looking for an agent
mm-hmm what steps should they take how
committed to that book should they be
how free should they be to say maybe
this isn't the one yeah I mean I think
you always I mean I think it's always
worth at the time when you write your
first book you'll be so attached to it
and so in love with it that it will be
heartbreaking if you don't get agented
or if it doesn't sell even though that's
really typical my advice is always once
you start the querying process is to
start writing your next book so you have
something else that you're focused on
and you know that it's not the end of
the road and all the times it might take
an author of several books before they
find an agent that is not uncommon the
things I really recommend are
workshopping a lot taking classes like
the ones I teach at the writing pad
which have a workshop component or I I
work shop the book that I sold the 13th
continuum with Meg Wolitzer who's one of
my favorite authors I also work shopped
with Victor Laval who's another one of
my favorite authors and I would go to
conferences and try to meet people and
just improve my writing for the querying
process it really is finding the agents
that you think are the best fit for your
material who are open to submissions and
then really following their guidelines
writing a great query letter spending a
lot of time getting that perfect and
then guess going through the process
publishing moves very slowly so it can
be months and months and months process
of even just hearing back from one
person and then once you're going on
submission it can also be months and
months and months and months because
they get inundated with so much material
so I think that the best way to handle
it is to then also be working on
something for yourself otherwise so you
have something ready to go if an agent
comes back to you and says hey I really
like your book but I'm not sure I can
sell this but I'd love to see what you
do next so then you have something to
say hey I'm going to be doing this next
and you can come back to them so for the
query letter did you have a template
that you found that you just kind of
change the names and dates and things
not to that extent I mean there is there
are good websites online that will show
the format so the four
right if something you really want to
follow and sticks to although I you know
I don't think you can really do just
like changing things because a lot of it
is like writing that really hooky
elevator pitch you know making sure you
have a great bio ready to go you know
that's you know concise and descriptive
because you know when they're looking at
your query letter that's the first
example of can you write well and so
your query letter really needs to be
written well and I also think ideally in
a tone that really reflects your book
which is to say especially the synopsis
like you know if your book is really
kind of snappy and witty then your
synopsis probably should be somewhat in
the same vein to convey that and then in
terms of personalizing it I think it
really is worthwhile when you're
querying agents to personalize to them
which is to show some knowledge about
what books they've represented what
types of genres they like if you were a
big fan like my agent had sold The Devil
Wears Prada which I absolutely loved you
know let them know that you loved this
book and that this you're coming to them
because you've been you know you know
who they are you know who their agency
is I think if you personalize and even
better if you have a personal connection
or some way like you've been at a
conference where they spoke even it
doesn't even have to be that you knew
them but I saw you on X panel at the AWP
conference and I was really impressed
and so I am coming to you so I think
that those things all helped a lot but a
lot of it is it's just like an editor
friend of mine who used to work at
HarperCollins she told me in the
beginning she's like it's like dating
she's like you're gonna go on a lot of
dates and I think that's really accurate
because you really are looking for the
right fit with an agent being on a
gentle is actually better than being
with a bad agent and it doesn't seem
like that would be the case but it is
someone who isn't a good fit for you or
isn't doing your work justice um can
actually do more damage then just on
even having an agent so I just think
it's very important to make sure that it
is the right fit for your material for
you because they really need to be your
cheerleader like they really are the
person that's going to be helping you
through the crazy process of trying to
find a publisher and ideally I think
also to find someone who's in
for the long-haul who's gonna stay with
you when your first book doesn't sell
because that's so common who's gonna be
there for your next book and he will
still represent you when you switch
genres and go back and say hey I'm
writing Wi-Fi now can we still do this I
was very lucky that my agent has been
amazing and has really stuck by me
through the whole process you know and
she's responsive like response to my
emails right away I know a lot of people
will struggle with that sometimes if
your agent is not getting back to you
yeah I think that's a real problem so
you know I think it's really important
to try to find the right person can you
give some other hypotheticals of how
being sort of on agented might be better
than being with the wrong parents yeah
there are a bunch of different ways I'm
when I used to go and speak either meet
with or speak with some pretty
well-known authors and they used to say
things like you know I'm so glad that my
first book didn't sell in retrospect and
it's really hard to see that at the time
because it will be heartbreaking but I
was hanging out with and raided booths
who wrote the House of Sand and Fog
which is a best-selling book he's been
on Oprah and his dad was like the
biggest short story author ever so the
guy had connections but I believe I
asked him the first book that you sold
how many of you Britain and I think he
said three or four it was quite a few
and this is a guy who actually had a
publishing connections and you know a
writing degree and all those fancy
things um and the thing about it is that
you know when you're first writing
you're really developing your craft and
you get better so a lot of times maybe
the first thing you write isn't quite in
the sweet spot of what you're supposed
to be writing and a lot of times you'll
look back and be like wow I really was
undeveloped it really is better that
this is the stage where I sold a book
and began off there is a little
different from some other creative
professions because you don't really age
out of it to the same degree I mean sure
you know publishing loves the young 22
year old who has a hit book like
Veronica Roth here at divergent yeah
they love that narrative but a lot of
times authors are gonna write their best
work when they get older
30 40 50 60 I mean Frank McCourt Herbert
Angela's Ashes I think he wrote that and
when he's 50 or 60 and it's one of my
favorite memoirs of all time a lot of my
favorite authors who are still producing
work are not young people Ursula Le Guin
artists like a kala Gwen's amazing I am
that's with Stephen King I think he's a
genius and I still read all of his books
and he's still publishing a ton I still
read Anne Rice but then there's other
people I know Philip Roth retired but
only recently I mean he was writing
books up until a couple years ago so and
I think a lot of times they're producing
their best work like Cormac McCarthy I
think is writing some of his best books
within the last ten years and he is not
a young man so I think that we develop
over the course of our writing careers
and I like to look at it as you know I
hope to write many many many books and I
hope to get better as I do so so really
kind of cultivating that
you